où est-ce que parce que vous m'avez pas
répondu clairement est-ce que clairement
vous allez faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait
pas de vote ou est-ce que vous souhaitez
qu'il y a un vote nous pensons que les
articles suivants l'article 7 mérite
beaucoup plus de débats que ce qui nous
est annoncé donc voilà donc on va nous
présenter nos amendements nous allons
présenter nos arguments nous allons
défendre nos explications de vote nous
allons faire parole sur article
amendements parce qu'il y a quasiment
4000 amendements de la gauche je me
retirer pas vos amendements pour aboutir
à votre finale
les amendements du groupe socialiste je
ne parle que de moi que de mon groupe
les amendes du groupe c'est moins de 500
amendements moins de 500 amendements que
pas énorme après il y a des amendements
individuels qui ont été déposés et
pourquoi ils ont été les bosets et bien
en prévention
de l'utilisation du fameux article 38
pour nous permettre de nous exprimer
quand même vous voyez c'est et on verra
bien comment se comporte les uns et les
autres donc
c'est fait pour voter bien sûr mais
est-ce qu'un parlementaire s'est fait
pour accepter le coup de force d'un
gouvernement c'est ça la question qui
nous est posée et nous nous disons non
nous ne voulons pas accepter le coût de
force du Gouvernement sur ce texte de
loi
gouvernement qui n'entend plus rien
enfin excusez-moi mais bon il y a
quelques mesures à quelques sucrettes
comme je les appelle par rapport à la
pilule amère que représente l'article 7
mais on est dans une forme de
bunkérisation aujourd'hui de l'exécutif
un président de la République qui
s'exprime pas d'ailleurs sur le sujet
des retraites ou très peu qui laisse
monter bien sûr je pense qu'il faut
qu'il s'exprime les Français vont lui
dire le 7 mars monsieur le Président
nous ne voulons pas de votre réforme
[Musique]